this is what a successful politician in
2021 looks like
yes i am uh running for uh the mayor of
london
my name is count pinkface and to
introduce myself uh
you may have known me from my uh
previous moniker
i i i didn't used to be called monica no
i used to be called uh lord
buckethead what's your policy on free
speech
well i wouldn't charge for it for a
start i'm for the bucket
i think it holds more water and he's
brian's biggest competitor right now
it's a narcissist versus a literal
bucket
so you want you want me to beat brian
rose that's what you want
oh yeah oh yeah that's like the first
priority
yeah i mean i mean i'd love to beat
brian um
electrically not physically i've seen it
he loves a bit of a shadow boxing
and i'm not looking for any uh fisty
cups
because i'll just shoot him with a laser
if it came to that but uh look
i i like standing for election partly
because it's a celebration
of democracy i think that democracy is
the single greatest political invention
in the entire galaxy
ladies and gentlemen welcome to a much
expected awaited
interview of my official endorsement
for mayor of london ladies and gentlemen
without further ado
count been faced he's joining us from
mars right now thank you
bob thank you very much coffeezilla
answer all your uh wonderful
fans viewers listeners however they
choose to imbibe me
sensually uh lovely to be here
now uh ca should i call you count
um how do i address you here yeah it
counts by
your excellency whatever your excellency
i i prefer
i much prefer your excellency okay now
tell the people who don't know you know
most people
they see you and they think man either
this guy's the greatest political
candidate of all time
or i think there may be some game going
on here
i don't treat you as a a game or a joke
at all tell people just how serious you
are about
running for mayor and uh also tell them
why they
you're such a better candidate well
i mean for a start i mean you can't look
more serious than this i mean
if you think i'm not serious then i
would quote the great john mcenroe and
say you can't be serious that's
i mean this is what a successful
politician in 2021 looks like i mean
yes i am uh running for uh the mayor of
london
my name is count pinkface and to
introduce myself uh
you may know of me from my uh previous
moniker
i i i didn't used to be called monica no
i used to be called
uh lord buckethead and i i ran against
uh theresa may the then prime minister
of the united kingdom
in uh earth year and
it was a lot of fun and uh i went viral
in a
non-covered kind of way you know the
good way
around your life just to be cool to be
viral yeah yeah exactly i went on john
oliver's show
spoke at the glastonbury festival all
sorts of lovely stuff
and then some american film producer
americans
you americans an american film producer
uh took control of my twitter account
after i got famous no i wanted to have
that title
for himself so i've upgraded
after my unfortunate battle on the
planet copyright and i'm back
i'm pin face and i'm ready to be may
you know it's a tough time when they
take you from buckethead to bendface but
i'm glad to see you've rolled with the
punches
um so now i mean obviously that's a very
serious issue but i i want to talk to
you about like
you know where you're from because
obviously this is an important issue for
any london candidate you know we have
people like
brian rose he's an american running for
mayor of london
i always thought that was a bit strange
but you you're from mars
going for uh for london yeah do i have
my facts right here
uh well i mean your facts about brian
rosa right
i believe he is an american trying to be
the mayor of london
and to me that's just crazy right
i mean that's just madness yeah with me
no no no no i'm from
i'm i'm compared to him i'm pretty much
uh
you know a local boy but uh i'm not from
mars
no uh i am from the uh sigma quadrant
but uh the uh the fact is that uh i've
come to your planet to run from air
and yet the intergalactic advice is to
remain at all times
at least one planet away from earth
while the pandemic's going on so i'm you
know i'm just taking precautions
i see you're you're s planetary
distancing
from us just to make sure these guys
figure it out
uh but you do want to help us out i
appreciate it i mean
i really do let me ask you um
you know it's not just brian rose you're
also up against
sadiq khan you're up against sean bailey
and i know you guys are shocked that i
know all these names but i'm interested
in uk politics this year this is the
year
that coffeezilla becomes a uk politician
fan
uh and i've chosen very carefully but
you're also up against a youtuber
named nico have you heard of this guy
he's like
hey hang on can i just stop you there
you mentioned we just roll back a second
you mentioned some of these candidates
you yeah you mentioned someone called
um sean bailey i think so that's is
that right i thought he's the
conservative whatever
is he no literally nobody knows honestly
no one knows who that candidate is it
could be him but he's whoever it is he's
running such a terrible campaign
no nobody can remember his name
at all which is why i asked you i am the
only one
that's shocking and an american barely
covering the election
i'm the only one that remembers yeah
what's it again
it's sean bailey i think that's it now
you're making me forget this
it goes in one side of the bin and
straight out the other i mean it's crazy
but anyway well thanks for that that was
handy
i mean yeah i know there's a couple of
youtube guys uh
running i think that their idea is to
use the election
to uh you know generate hits for their
own
right they're not youtube platforms i
mean
uh that's fine that's part of democracy
i suppose but uh
you know my concern is that that's
that's what's gonna happen more and more
in all your countries that are
you know the entirety of politics could
be uh run by
20 somethings claiming that they're
trying to prank
the news when they're possibly doing no
such thing
i think it's such a shame when people
treat the election like a joke
um and that's what exactly i mean who
would do a thing like that
yeah yeah it's it's true that's very
true
um so sorry is your bin getting a little
a little full a little stuffy over there
it's full of politics it's absolutely
brimming full of ideas
okay so speaking of ideas i want to tell
tell the people
you're not a guy with no ideas like
brian rose he's like hey what are you
for
science and that's all he can tell you
he doesn't know anything no no
you have some real specific ideas now i
was really drawn to your croissant idea
i said this
is a big idea can you tell the people
what you want the croissant law to be
just so they know what they're getting
with you of course well just to start
just to go back to brian
uh you it to be fair to the guy i mean
there's a there's a lot of things which
are quirky about
your mate brian rose yeah but uh one
thing i will say if in the united
kingdom
for an american to say he is pro-science
is not taken for granted so actually you
know given your former president
for brian to say that is is a is a
pretty big deal because
some americans uh you know don't believe
in science
uh and that's that's up to them you know
if they want to believe what they want
to believe but uh
i'm pleased that brian at least accepts
things like
the law of gravity and things like that
because i don't think
the impression that some of the
candidates like piers corbin
he's probably not too sure about that
kind of thing you know
5g conspiracies anti-vaxx conspiracy
oh no brian brian did all that brian did
the the
had david ike on he was fracturing with
all those ideas
of course there you go that's strange
that brian would say he's pro science
and yet uh uh talk to her to davis
politicians use every good idea like a
little
a cudgel to beat their little uh
constituents over the head with they
is science fam the word of the day i'll
be pro
science yeah and in reality they're not
um
so no but no but get me back to
you've derailed my whole croissant plan
here or
yeah if you want me to elaborate i will
now
i mean let's go back to basics a
croissant
is a small excuse me pastry base
butter filled ready snack
okay everyone's happy with that it
emanated from
the great country of france but like a
pandemic it has swept
across the globe and uh thanks to me
uh hopefully uh my quadrant will soon be
uh
picking up some uh exports but
and this is the big but in recent times
in good old london town the price
of a single croissant has skyrocketed
faster than the property prices
you've gone from 50p to a single item
to like you took one pound fifty two
pound two pound fifty in some places
it's a tragedy
it's madness and i'm telling you
coffeezilla
i mean your name is coffee you must know
about snacks at breakfast this
has got to stop and i am an
egalitarian bin and i say
on day one i would lobby for
all hey outlets and shops and
anything anywhere that wants to sell a
croissant come on guys
make it a quick that's it no more than a
quid
guys that's the new thing so no shop
maybe is allowed to sell a croissant for
more than one quid
i like there's something bold to that i
really enjoy that
uh because it is true these shopkeepers
they're getting cocky
they are and the thing is what do you
call it that's still a pretty bloody
decent markup isn't it
i quit you can't tell me that they've
got to make
i'm not buying that at all i literally
would not buy that
so uh you know all i'm saying is give
the customers
they're on their way to work you know
london transport is a bit of a nightmare
anyway and that's without crossrail
being built and we can come on to that
you know i i all i'm saying is give
something
back to the great british londoner
okay i like that bold idea and that's
exactly the kind of bullet idea that i
support which is why i'm endorsing you
for mayor of london so i expect all the
coffeezilla army to go out
vote for not me
don't vote because i told you to vote
for ben face
for yourself do yourself a favor do
yourself
and your croissant little stomach a
favor and go vote for count been face
because he's the only you're the only
politician
i've ever seen address these critical
issues now um
other critical issues that i want to
talk to you about is your radical
approach
to punishment related to some of these
ideas now you want to
ban speaker phones on public transport
now most people would say okay i'm gonna
you know if you break this law
i by the way i agree speaker phones on
public transport
get some airpods guys um but if you do
break that tell them what happens it's
not what they think
uh well i mean it's up to your
uh your fans and your good self to say
what you think
uh the punishment should be for somebody
being anti-social
and using speakerphone on public
transport but my
my philosophy is a simple one that you
need to have
the carrot on the one hand
and the stick on the other now that
means
yes i'm prepared to offer commuters
the one pound croissants that's on the
table i'm offering that
that is there i you know that's a
promise yes but
you know i'd be lying if i said there
weren't
strings attached yeah and my number one
string
is please don't be a dick
on public transport and if you do i've
got a simple philosophy
i'm not into tasers i'm more of a lasers
kind of guy
and i'm not into what americans do which
is uh
shooting innocent people i try not to do
watch out
there's a lot of americans watching this
right now yeah go ahead yeah
yeah you know i i i think that's a bit
much
so instead i have a third way
yes and it's simple i say any offender
caught using speakerphone must be forced
to watch the movie version of
cats every day or a year
and that will stop them
i guarantee it i think some people would
rather be shot
i mean quite frankly but i do like i i
admire the radicalness
of this plan i don't think any
politician has been willing to approach
such
radical um punishment ideas
now do you feel like that's it is a
pretty steep punishment but
maybe the punishment fits the crime i
don't know
well i mean this is the thing uh uh
my policy rather like everything in your
universe is
uh as einstein put it relative so
you know if you say oh being made to
watch
the movie of cats every day for a year
sounds
pretty steep well yeah that is steep
compared to
not having to watch it every day for a
year correct
but it's pretty lenient compared to
making them watch it every day for
a hundred years which i could have said
so you know
what a politician's got to do is
everything is about
moderation it's about finding the
mainstream it's about
finding and charting a middle course
and all i'm doing here is sitting here
chatting to you having a very sober
discussion
about politics and about the sensible
way
forwards to ensure a reduction
in anti-social behavior this this
couldn't be
more sane i agree
but is this a typical galactic style
punishment i mean i i feel like
when we think about earthly punishments
we think about you know very
straightforward things
are we a little primitive have we not
gone far enough to get creative
with the way that we incentivize
behaviors
well i mean yeah yes you are primitive
yeah and you say you haven't gone far
enough you guys are stuck on your bloody
planet so i mean you don't get much more
primitive than that
yeah you know yeah you said a couple of
guys up to the moon
and you've sent a bloody drone up here
to miles which is really pissing me off
i honestly you got to get a license for
these things i mean
you you guys you really take liberties
but yeah
are you are primitive and that's why you
deserve uh primitive punishment so
i'd be lying if i said that i had forced
anyone else in the universe to watch the
movie version of
cats as a punishment or otherwise
uh i that that would be not true no i
can guarantee you
no other being in the entire multiverse
has seen the movie cat it's just you
guys it's your problem
you created it and therefore all i'm
doing is serving it back up to you
it's true um i can't argue with that
listen
so i gotta we i mean we have so much to
talk about so i gotta we're gonna move
on
from each of these things because you've
got other big policies and my point in
doing this
is that when i first announced that i
would be endorsing you as the mayoral
candidate of london
you know i couldn't believe it but
people actually did think i was joking
and i said
no are you are you joking this guy's a
serious candidate they said come on
stephen
count binface and i said no it's it's
real man
he used to be lord buckethead now he's
count ben face you got to take a second
look
so one of my things here is i really
want to present your fresh ideas to
people
now another of your fresh ideas is that
loud
snacks to be banned from theaters
hey i for one can endorse this but my
question is
what counts as a loud snack
well firstly thank you for endorsing my
policy i mean this one's just a
no-brainer
absolutely no-brainer what does the b
stand for
the b on your coffee cup what does that
stand for oh it's supposed to be a
coffee break
cb oh i see a club
channel because you see cb is what we're
doing here
wow yeah in a way it's kind of it's kind
of an endorsement here accountability
it's kind of an endorsement
i mean there were certain americans
who'd see that and they'd try and uh do
you for copyright just using the old
initials there but
no i'm not going to do that you i love
it free advertising
you you you go ahead have you been face
mark lovely
so look let's get back to theaters the
thing is right
it it's got to stop i when you say what
counts as a loud snack
the question is can you hear them eating
if the answer is yes it's too bloody
loud
that's that's what i'm talking about
here now
some people might say this is uh
you know a little bit over the top i
mean what i should say is
and it's a semantic issue here
between uh the uk and america because
uh you guys uh use the word uh theater
to represent both uh you know going to
take in a show
and cinemas where you go a movie theater
that's true
now i'm not saying i'm not doing the
cinemas here i'm starting this slow
again
i'm moderate i'm reasonable yes
i have a bin for the head but i'm not
stupid well i'm not completely stupid
so i'm talking about the theatrical
places
the what you would call it a playhouse
maybe so
it's where people have spent loads of
money
to go and see people performing live and
you go in
and there's someone to your left to your
right or behind you
scoffing their faces with crisps
and a boiled sweets and and they're like
and it makes me think firstly what's
your problem
and secondly why can't you find a quiet
snack
like a little uh a soft map something
like that
and thirdly why can't you
eat before the show
i mean you knew you're gonna go and see
the show
and you know that the show is about
watching something
why don't you eat before you go in i
don't under look you're the human here
what's going on i'll tell you what's
going on listen i'll be honest
at theaters i love a good snack but i'm
talking about the movie theaters
but i've gone to plays before and i find
it absolutely deplorable to people who
eat at theaters because
uh the like the like plays stuff like
that it is hard to hear they don't have
these crazy sound systems
if you go to like star wars the latest
star wars
cinema as you uh you guys call it which
is i think's weird
but if you if you go to that you're
going to be blown out no matter what
you're eating i mean you're not going to
hear anybody eating because it's so loud
speakers but i
at plays and stuff you can barely hear
um somebody's crunching you know some
chips next to you it's a disaster so i
agree with you but
um i i agree with you there we go but on
the other hand
you don't have a punishment for this one
and part of me thinks
did did you know your excellency forget
to include a punishment and could we
right now spin up a punishment for the
violators of this crime
uh well i mean i i didn't come up with a
punishment
because i i i was i was trying to be
reasonable
you know i again this is me
i'm i can't i honestly can't believe i'm
saying this but compared to the other 19
candidates
you're talking to the same one and and
you know
i've come over here from the sigma
quadrant and i
if i say to you guys come on let's not
have the snacks
when you're going to see a play that
should be it right
that you shouldn't need an intergalactic
to threaten you with you know a battle
army
armed with lasers or you know a james
corden movie
featuring horrendously animated cats you
shouldn't need me to do that
yeah but it should be simple it's like
you know
if i say don't slap the
next person you see across the street in
the face
you shouldn't need me to say because if
you do i'll arrest you just not you're
just not gonna do it
but that's the human condition you tell
us don't slap the next person i
guarantee you about five people
that are watching this right now are
gonna go do that not because they were
going to do it because you told
him not to do it whose problem is that
well it's the person getting slapped
that's whose problem it is um
so may well we'll put a pin in that
we'll put a pin in the
punishment i'll you know we'll have to
update that because i'm telling you you
can't just tell people anything you
gotta
you've always gotta consider hang on if
you i'm quite happy coffee zilla i am
quite happy
on your program your youtube
program uh whatever this is what i don't
know what you watch you want to call it
a transmission whatever it is
yes i'll give you an exclusive go ahead
okay
right here right now if
someone if i was to catch
anyone in a bin face meryl t
eating a loud snack during a play
i'd make them watch the movie version of
cats
for two years how about that
wow you know you're a fair
but firm leader
uh count bitface i i do have to say that
now okay my my slogan used to be uh
strong but not entirely stable
that's what i'm giving you right thank
you thank you uh this is that's a good
coffee still exclusive
now we have people like brian rose
saying they're fans of
free speech but then copywriting all my
videos
um that are talking about anything
related to him
or you know really any anytime i talk
about a mayoral candidate he always
copyrights it
how do you feel about free speech are
you better than that
and and after this we got to talk about
sadiq
khan but i imagine sadiq doesn't strike
me as the free speech guy either
well they're two very different people
yeah brian and siddique so let's uh
let's deal with them intent brian was
now
let's just let's just uh you know drill
down into this one let's say rummage
through the bin that is brian's uh
meryl campaign now look you mentioned
copyright now i have
a little teeny weeny experience of
copyright
on your planet yes you can't tell me
that you talking about brian
is a breach of copyright it isn't right
so how on earth is he able to strike a
claim against you
he just tells youtube that it's his
content well then they listen to him
yeah yeah that actually it's real i get
yeah
yeah absolutely so so he could do that
with this broadcast now
yeah we're not gonna show any images of
brian or anything like that
but uh i'll give you an example so i
played
somebody else's reporting of brian rose
with this guy uh this great interviewer
on mail mailplus
and i played that broadcast so brian
didn't own it he
said he owned it and copyright claimed
it anyways
so these are things that he doesn't even
own he'll just copyright it
but can't you just say to youtube that's
wrong yeah but then it takes like 15
14 days to come back up and at which
point the video is already dead
which means it's already dead you mean
it's it's lost it's been blocked
for 14 days yeah it kind of lost its uh
yeah it's 14 days
news old like it's a lot of news is
topical
ah right well uh let's get into it let's
have a little chat about this is one of
my problems with the with your news
cycle that uh everything is so bloody
instantaneous and correct everything has
to be
you know up now and down and now and
videos keep going i mean i saw a thing
you
you managed to do 100 videos in a
hundred days which is amazing but
but it's that sense that there's so much
content going up
i would reassure you that if if if your
video
goes back up eventually and remember
this election is going to be gone
in like a week or so time from the time
we're chatting to each other so
you know the history of brian rose will
outlive the uh the actual election
itself by many many millennia well until
the asteroid comes and gets you uh
sorry about that but uh nothing i can
well i could do something about it but
i'm not going to
that's your problem but uh yeah until
that day
you know brian will have to live with
you and other journalists
you know trenchantly examining uh what
he says and whether they are true
or whether they are uh porcupines but uh
it's so
i i would be relaxed about it i really
would you know if he wants to go along
and say to youtube
you can't use that that's mine well
he'll get found out in the end
i think he will i think he will too um
but my question to you
is what's your policy on free speech
are you about it are you like what's the
galactic policy on free speech
well i wouldn't charge for it for a
start i think free speech should
should be free and uh you know i this
that's one of the reasons why i
stand for election uh coffee zilla yeah
or cough
should i call you cough i don't i don't
really know what the shot shortens
versus
so this is the way i see it did it
i i like standing for election partly
because it's a celebration of democracy
i think that democracy is the single
greatest political invention
in the entire galaxy wow uh
yeah i can guarantee you were we the
first ones to invest
you know what were we the first ones to
invent the democracy
oh no no i did but uh don't worry about
that the ancient greeks caught up with
me eventually but i got it you know but
the point is
it it's an incredible invention and you
guys in certain countries
are still using it and it's under attack
i think that's terrible it needs
defending it needs celebrating and one
of the things that's wonderful about
british democracy
is that in the year 2021
you can stand for an election to be the
mayor of the earth capital
even if you wear a bin on your head
and i think that's fantastic of course
you have to pay 10 000 pounds for the
entry fee which uh
you could argue that's not exactly
helping free speech
but uh you know thanks to a bunch of
lovely earthlings i managed to cobble
the
the cash together and uh here i am so
free speech is very much
my thing and i say i'm all for it
that's a wonderful answer you're going
to get a lot of votes for that one
a lot of votes are coming to you from
that one i figure now
how much are we behind and i say we
because i'm just injecting myself into
your campaign
um how much leech into the army
injecting meter
i'm joining the army how much do we need
to bring forward
number one to beat brian rose that's my
number one goal but two
to beat the whole win the whole thing
outright and get one dollar croissants
one quid croissants excuse me
so you want you want me to beat brian
rose that's what you want
oh yeah oh yeah that's like the first
priority
yeah i mean i mean i'd love to beat
brian um
electorally not physically i've seen it
he loves a bit of a shadow boxing
there's brian i'm not looking for any uh
fisty cups because i'll just shoot him
with a laser if it came to that but
look i i i wish brian the very best for
his campaign
i'll be honest with you uh he's not
gonna win
and uh he says he's gonna win he's not
gonna win
and he spent an awful lot of money and
it would be much nicer if uh he'd maybe
um made a lovely large donation to
charity and said you know what i might
as well stay at home
but that's my personal view as for uh me
uh
winning the uh mayoral race um well
that's not gonna happen either because
uh you know i'm coming in
from a standing start and uh the truth
is i've been
isolating up here on mars i haven't been
doing uh much uh
pressing the flash uh walking the walk
because uh
there's a there's a pandemic going on if
you if you haven't heard and i think
it's important to respect
that there are bigger things going on
but uh but you know uh if if i
if i'd had my old name and uh the whole
world still knew
me as my old name yeah who knows but uh
i i think
that uh uh you never know account bin
face score uh in somewhere of the region
of two percent would be a huge
landmark victory for uh
waste receptacle-shaped politics in the
uk
if i could get five percent i would
retain my ten thousand pound deposit
and donate it to shelter to help combat
homelessness so uh you know come on
londoners you know what to do
uh uh help out bin face try and beat
some of the loonies
and uh maybe we can uh help a good cause
as well
lovely jumbly lovely jubbly okay
that's a great into our interview here
actually i really
thank you for great answers your last
two answers have been wonderful
um all the rest of them have been good
as well thank you for coming on and
sharing
your big ideas sometimes i think we
always say you need to think outside the
box and in this case we're
really going outside the galaxy and i
think that's the right maybe the right
place
to start so uh ladies and gentlemen this
has been
my official endorsement for mayor of
london
the man himself he's full of it count
been face
thank you appreciate you lovely to be
here
all the best everyone look after
yourselves stay safe
and uh see you
[Music]
trying to sell soon on a dream but that
was where you lost me
wake up and smell the coffee